[Musique]
hop hop hop hop hop on vite patron bon
nous sommes enfin arrivés je descends
d'urgence voir le malade europe pape au
pow pow pow pow
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants et oui nous avons un
malade ce soir notre petite amie
cornichons mais heureusement nounours
occupe de nuit
bon pas bon alors où se trouve notre
malheur d'un achat il est bien beau
chant état d'un sommeil le surveille et
pourquoi
bon va lui annoncer que le torpeur
arrivants y en a déjà qui s
[Musique]
non non ce oui mais le docteur ce n'est
pas nécessaire puisqu'il y en a déjà
mon petit corps du chant me tuer tout
rouge oh la la ce que tu es roues
évidemment puisqu'il à la rougeole
déjà d'idées devenue la rougeole avec
une tout pareil la rougeole heureusement
que nounours est venue de soigner tu as
une bonne grippe mon cher nounours je me
connais âmes analyse infantile c'est la
rougeole pepita donne à notre malade son
sirop rouges anti rougeole ces
bouteilles à cette bouteille ou
cornichons au dessus font toujours
désirer et dur où l'attend mon petit
cornichons attends j'ai quelque chose de
meilleur vous croyez m'en cherno more we
data voilà du sirop verts on plante un
et aux fleurs des prairies pour la toux
tiens pépite a fait boire ton ami
johnny chan d'ici rhône ont alors
avec celui là tu seras guérisse c'est
vrai pourquoi pas mais pas trop mauvais
alors je me levais puisque tous ces
sirops c'est guéri non mon petit
cornichons pour la rougeole il faut
beaucoup de chaleur c'est pour ça que tu
laisses la fenêtre ouvert
pour la toux également ghd ne pouvait
retenir ou y rajoute pepita et couvre
toi bien
au
delà g
c'est ce qu'ils font à présent un bon
sommeil et demain tu n'auras plus de
fièvre et tu sera guérie tu pourras tête
manger mais oui tu pourras manger autant
que tu veux à damier alors je vais
guérir à longs poils de nuit et soit
sérieux pas d'extravagance
je veille nounours soyez sans crainte au
revoir docteur data on revoir d'actair
nous hb je vous raconte agne docteur
venu et nous nous sommes devenus
banals nuit confrères
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors comment se porte cornichons pour
lemieux patron il a seulement une petite
grippe rougeole et nous l'avons bien
soigné il est presque guérie très bien
nous voilà rassurés sur la santé de
cornichons bonnut les enfants allez vite
vous coucher à deux tours
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
hamon
[Musique]